bueno dejar que empiece con una pregunta
es sencilla así que por favor ser
honestos todos vale por favor que
levanten la mano aquel que haya mentido
al menos una vez en los últimos cinco
años
de las personas que habéis levantado la
mano por favor decirme cuáles os
consideráis buenas personas o personas
honestas
vale somos mentirosos esto es
pero esto no es malo usamos la mentira y
la mentira es un mecanismo que usamos
sistemáticamente y de hecho parte de la
sociedad la construimos a través de
mentiras hoy voy a hablar de una mentira
muy especial es las mentiras que nos
hacemos a nosotros mismos y de hecho voy
a hablar de las mentiras que nos hacemos
a nosotros mismos en un momento muy
especial de nuestra vida
que es cuando montamos un negocio es muy
curioso porque en ese momento afloran
muchas cosas en nuestra cabeza y es muy
interesante como usamos estos mecanismos
y como los intentamos superar
he tenido la suerte de trabajar con
muchos emprendedores montando startups
básicamente son negocios de base
tecnológica e innovadores en los cuales
hay un contexto de incertidumbre extremo
muy alto no y ya tenía suerte ya no solo
de montarlas yo mismo como emprendedor
sino también poder trabajar con ellos
mano a mano y he descubierto una serie
de mecanismos que se repiten con mucha
frecuencia son tres mecanismos que usan
los emprendedores para quererse sus
propias mentiras básicamente esto
llamamos sesgos un sesgo es una forma en
la cual distorsionamos la realidad
pensamos que es de una forma cuando
realmente no lo es así que dejar que os
cuente estos tres sesgos que usamos los
emprendedores para querernos nuestras
propias mentiras es mejor dejar que os
cuenten cómo poder superar esto vale el
primer sesgo el primero de todos es muy
frecuente se arma el sesgo por falacia
de planificación básicamente consiste en
hacer un plan de negocio y quererse todo
lo que escribes en el plan de negocio
consiste básicamente en creer que todas
las cosas van a ser como tú quieres que
sean incluso pensar que tu producto será
más rápido más bonito más barato que la
de la competencia y aún nos empezó ni
siquiera fabricarlo
bueno este tipo de sesgos lo sufrimos
constantemente y es curioso porque
cuando uno crea un negocio es muy
difícil hacer un plan es muy difícil
predecir los planes de negocio son
herramientas predictivas me ayudan a
predecir aquello que va a ocurrir pero
es muy difícil predecir aquello que
nunca te ha pasado por mucho que te
esperes en hacer un plan de negocio
perfecto es que si lo pensáis bien pedir
un plan de negocio a un emprendedor
antes de tener su negocio
es como perder a cristóbal colón un mapa
del mundo antes de salir de españa es
que no encontró una isla encontré un
continente [ __ ] y esto y normal tiempo
'cristóbal colón' la pregunta es quién
se iba imaginar un continente ahí en
medio lo mismo ocurre con los
emprendedores y es verdad es muy difícil
imaginarse cosas hasta que no ocurre hay
un ejemplo buenísimo de una startup muy
famosa que tuvo este tipo de sesgo
seamos iridium quizá os suene iridium
porque a día de hoy sigue operando pero
yo fue uno de los casos más
espectaculares de este tipo de sesgos de
falacia de planificación básicamente fue
el año 94 un grupo de emprendedores
visionarios tuve unidad que cambió el
mundo su idea básicamente consistía en
crear un sistema de telecomunicaciones
global en el año 94 existían los
teléfonos móviles pero no era obvio de
que todo el mundo iba a tener un
teléfono muy bueno uno o dos teléfonos
móviles pero la clave no fue esa la
clave es que su idea consistía en crear
lo global así que para eso tenían que
lanzar 77 satélites al espacio para dar
cobertura vía satélite a todo el planeta
los inversores cuando escucharon esta
idea en el año 94 se les haría los
billones por los bolsillos de hecho
iridium levantó cinco mil millones de
dólares para lanzar los satélites
deslumbró mucho efectivamente y fue
increíble porque trabajaron como
animales para lanzar los satélites pero
pensar que fabricaron siete les es caro
pero la forma espacio también es caro y
cuando estaban los satélites en el
espacio cuando se que era la red y usan
los terminales y llaman y ven que
funcionan ya pensaban que iban a recoger
los millones del mercado su objetivo 500
millones de potenciales clientes en el
mundo
fue el año 2000 aquella increíble hazaña
nos es acordar 'aces' del año 2000 pero
el año 2000
teníamos en españa' airtel recordarte no
teníamos amena que él ha vuelto a
resurgir en el año 2000 fue cuando
ericsson os acordáis la conexión de la
tapitas acordáis era chiquitín que se
abría si la capital a entre la
chiquitina y motorola sacó el ub
acordáis que era el start ecb dv craft
chiquitín que en todo aquí en el
monedero que no tiene la vocal orejas
acordes de aquel no pues pues justo en
aquel momento fue cuando iridium sacó
sus terminales al mercado fueron más o
menos como estos que vais a ver en ese
momento sacaron esos terminales claro
que sí
el primero es espectacular la antena es
de una estética increíble la gente
llegaba a la tienda de telefonía decía
oye estos teléfonos que que se puede
hacer con ellos se puede hablar usted
quiera donde quiera y donde quiera estás
subiendo el himalaya por una conference
call con su jefe está a mitad del
pacífico por llamar a su mujer
es increíble no sé si es una pregunta
pero la antena se puede girar no
[ __ ] qué cómodo el móvil por aquí la
antena para que saliendo es
iridium quebró en ocho meses
y de un quebranto ocho meses es curioso
porque hasta que no tienes las cosas en
la mano no sabes cómo se comporta el
mundo y el mercado el segundo sesgo en
segundos en los que va a contar os es un
sesgo terrible no es el sesgo en el cual
piensas sea más falso consenso el sesgo
por falso consenso piensas que todo el
mundo tiene los mismos problemas que
tienes tú esto es muy típico de
emprendedores les ocurre un problema no
encuentro algo en internet piensa que
todo el mundo tiene por frank otras
cosas a internet se me pierden los niños
de todo el mundo se pierde los niños y
básicamente este mecanismo los trapo las
a todo el mundo pensado que el tamaño
mercado es mucho más grande de lo que
realmente es
bueno se entiende muy bien este este
sesgo con un caso que viví muy cercano
estuve con una startup que su idea
básicamente consistía en desarrollar
unas pulseras unos wearable sabéis no
estas pulseras pequeñitas consistían
básicamente en poder posicionar
exactamente ese problema a los niños
cuando se perdían básicamente le ponían
a pulsar al niño con el móvil la
controlaba si en ese momento bueno pues
ayer estaba el niño pero su problema que
quieren resolver muy obvio perder a tu
hijo si te le preguntó es un padre
quieres perder a tu hijo
depende de la edad
si tienes 25 años sí pero pero de 10
años para abajo que todavía molan y son
agentes para aquí todas también [ __ ]
ningún padre quiere perderlo es como
obvio no nos costó muchísimo empezar a
convencernos de salir a preguntar de
hecho en un principio
elegimos diferentes segmentos de
clientes de acuerdo que fueron los
campamentos de verano al summer camp
hablamos de los colegios de las
guarderías y lo que hicimos fue salir a
hablar con guarderías hablamos con 15
directoras de guardería para intentar
entender el problema a ver si realmente
estaba ocurriendo y fue curioso pero
cuando estamos delante de los directores
de la guardería la primera entrevista
nos sentábamos dimos hola buenas tardes
muchas gracias por su tiempo somos una
startup que estamos intentando entender
los problemas que tenéis en las
guarderías y nos gustaría saber qué tipo
de plomo tenéis cuando perdiste un niño
la guardería
no no no perdemos niños
con algún niño haber perdido la
granja-escuela en el museo por ahí no
que no no no si yo no tengo 25 años con
la guardería y no ha perdido un niño en
la vida
seguimos dando entrevistas de hecho unas
enfadó muchísimo dijo pero vosotros
quiero estar ahí en ayuntamiento que
esto para qué es
fue brutal porque una una by nos dice ya
al final estamos desquiciados los
últimos entrevistas dice joven que es
una pulsera valoraron niños y tenerlos
controlados y no se pierdan y va y dice
mira chaval en esta guardería tenemos
protocolos de seguridad que conocemos
todos los profesores de la guardería y
da igual la [ __ ] que pongas al niño en
la muñeca
no voy a cambiar ninguno de los
protocolos seguras que tengo de la
guardería así que esto no aporta ningún
valor
cómo mola escuchar esto en dos semanas
cómo jode escuchar esto en dos años su
boca está es la gran diferencia de una
startup cuando aprende rápido es decir
cause terrible así que cuidado no
penséis que vuestro primero tiene todo
el mundo quizá los problemas que
nosotros tenemos son nuestros y no son
fáciles de transportar a otras personas
y el tercer tipo de sesgo es
posiblemente el peor de todos lo
llamamos el sesgo por coste este sesgo
es la razón por la cual un emprendedor
cuanto más tiempo dedica a su producto o
servicio más le cuesta cambiar lo más es
la visión que él quiere sin escuchar lo
que pide el mercado y se puede pegar
años desarrollando un producto y cada
vez le cuesta más cambiarlo hay ejemplos
terribles de todo esto posiblemente uno
de los que me encontré y tuve la suerte
de ser mentor fue algo espectacular en
un chico que su vida era interesantísima
además era social era bien bonita lo que
intenta básicamente es evitar tirar
comida a la basura es terrible porque es
casi un tercio de la comida que
trabajamos y elaboramos se tira la
basura es terrible pero el objetivo
básicamente era desarrollar una
plataforma que de hecho lo hizo
desarrolló un entorno web una
herramienta online y una aplicación
móvil para que por comunidades
pudiera compartir alimentos de tal forma
de que si no se el primero es un chico
joven que come bocatas todo el día y la
del cuarto es una señora mayor que hace
lentejas pues un día sobre lentejas que
el primero pueda comer lentejas y puedo
comer hierro vale era un poco la
historia para evitar tirar comida porque
además lo curioso es tirar comida es que
nadie la comida lo que haces es la pones
la nevera y cuando se pudre no tienes la
comida realmente la nevera si la basura
y lo pensáis bien pero este concepto
cuando lo preguntábamos la gente era muy
muy clara decía tú quieres tirar comida
a la basura no quiero decir nada no pero
hicimos un experimento intentamos ver
qué pasaba en el comportamiento de las
personas porque las opiniones todo
quedaba muy claro pero en los
comportamientos descubrimos algo
terrible descubrimos un concepto que
llamamos el asquito
qué es el asquito el asquito es lo
siguiente por ejemplo imaginaros que yo
estoy en casa comiendo crisis nos hace
lentejas para todos para los niños para
mí que si mi mujer y bueno con los dos
lentejas y de repente me encuentro un
pelo de cris bueno pues es un pelo de
crisis pero si comiendo las lentejas de
la del cuarto a mitad de cuchara me
encuentro un pelo el momento de tirar
del pelo de la boca a ese momento
lo llamamos asquito
y el asquito es la razón por la cual
seguimos tirando un tercio de la comida
a la basura
terrible el ser humano como es yo no no
es cuestión de juzgarlos somos como
somos para lo bueno y para lo malo pero
lo brutal de todo esto es que se dio
cuenta rapidísimamente que el problema
que quería resolver no se podía resolver
con la herramienta que había
desarrollado llevaba un año
desarrollando la y sabéis lo que me dijo
cuando perdimos todo eso dijo
bueno ya que estamos aquí hagamos el
producto
a eso se le llama sesgo por coste
terrible estos ojos que tenéis delante
ha visto liquidar estar estás por este
tipo de sesgo
bueno intentos contaros los tres esos
más típicos que tenemos cuando montamos
un negocio hay más sin lugar a duda pero
estos son muy frecuentes y cualquiera
aquí en la sala que quiera
bueno pues montar un negocio crear una
startup sufrir a esos sesgos porque yo
mismo montando las los he sufrido quizá
la pregunta que tenéis todo este momento
es para néstor cómo superamos estos
sesgos o sea cómo somos capaces de
intentar no creernos nuestras propias
mentiras bueno pues el mecanismo que
usamos las startups y los emprendedores
para resolver esto se llama
el método científico
así exactamente nada nuevo en el
horizonte lo que hacemos es aplicamos
los mismos fundamentos de la
experimentación para aprender
rápidamente porque lo que hacemos es de
nuestra idea de negocio identificamos
las hipótesis más arriesgadas que
tenemos desde esa hipótesis construimos
experimentos y pruebas algunos os lo he
contado con esos ejemplos y esos
experimentos nos muestran los hechos los
hechos nos gustarán o no nos gustarán
pero son hechos y con los hechos vemos y
validamos o invalida mos nuestros
supuestos o hipótesis así que a esto en
general le llamamos line startup es un
mecanismo en el cual construimos
productos y negocios basado en la
validación con el cliente en el
conocimiento validado y en la
experimentación científica hoy en día
cuando se crea un negocio de base
tecnológica e innovadora hay mucha
incertidumbre hay más cosas que no
sabemos que las que sabemos y en vez de
crear nuestras propias mentiras lo que
hacemos es experimentar y probar
rápidamente así que intento en mis
propios negocios y en los que puedo
colaborar ayudar o formar parte
intento trabajar sistemáticamente este
enfoque científico así que recomiendo
que cualquiera que esté aquí quiera
montar un negocio mantenga este enfoque
científico para no quererse
mentiras pero
os voy a contar una cosa que he
aprendido con los años
aún así aunque las mentiras no son
buenas y deciros que hay algunas
mentiras que si lo son y que hay
mentiras que nos ayudan muchísimo y que
nos llevan mintiendo toda la vida es más
de pequeño nos decían que no se podía
mentir que si mentía éste crecía la
nariz pero seguimos una mentira o sea
nos enseñaban con mentiras
pero no está mal de hecho las mentiras
nos ayudan en la vida nos ayudan a
emprender los años a nuestro ayudar a
estudiar nos ayuda a superarnos a
nosotros mismos muchos deportistas
cuando están en el límite no pueden más
y yo muero cuando llega aquella esquina
paro pero cuando ya no les quiera no
paran se han mentido siguen corriendo la
mentira es poderosísima sí sabemos
utilizarla sin algo manejar la mentira
es brutal porque lo que sí os puedo
decir es que es posible entender un
mundo en el cual la mentira también nos
haga ser buenas personas muchas gracias
[Aplausos]